はい
なるほど
把握した
みなさんハンドスピナーというものはご存知でしょうか？
もうYouTuberたりやこぞいもこぞってハンドスピナーの動画だしやがってほんと
め！め！とかいいながら僕もやるんですけどもー
そんなねしょうもないことハンドスピナーでしたくないんで
そもそもしょうもないし
どうせだったらもっと
ハンドスピナーを使って凄いことができないかなと思いまして
はいこちらハンドスピナーですね！
こうすれば回るやつです
こうやって回すと指の間でずっと回ってるっていう
なんとも、、なんとも特徴のないおもちゃですけども
僕はこのハンドスピナーのある特徴に目をつけました
これ形を見てもらったらわかると思うんですけど
いかにも
そうなんです。僕はそこに目を付けてしまった
ハンドスピナーがたとえばもう1個あると、
こう繋げれるんじゃないかと僕思いまして
そんなスピードは出ないんですけど、１つを回すと、周りのやつも回るという
こういう原理があると思いまして、
こういう感じで周りのも回るんですよ
てな感じです。
ハンドスピナーを1つ回しては
他の周りのやつも全部回るんじゃねぇかと思いまして
ﾜｧﾔｯﾍﾞ投げちゃった....もし、この原理で行くと
ここに今1000個の
ハンドスピナーがあるんですけれども、ひょっとしたら指一本で、ハンドスピナーが1000個
一気に回せるかもしれない
もうできるかわかんない
できるかわかんないし、おそらくできても...高速回転なんて出来やしない
それでもいい
それでもいいんです
ハンドスピナーのこの回りやすい性質
無駄に歯車チックでフィットしそうな感じ！
僕はそのハンドスピナーを
指一本で
1000個回したいんです
では行こう
ゴメン...では行こうとか言ったけど、
後2箱あるんだ
うっ　うぅーん
そもそも1000個並べられるのか？俺の家に
話はそこからDA！！！
別の箱になってるなぁ
うーーあーー...よいしょ
こん中に入っとるんか？
うわぁやべぇこれ
全部ハンドスピナーだからね？
ねぇ　待って赤じゃん！やったぁ
あ、青だ！
黄色黄色きいｒ！
ししし.しし.......白！
そもそもハンドスピナーが1000個
1か所の集まること自体
そうそうない無いことだと思うので、
とりあえず！ハンドスピナー1000個...箱から出して、
回せる状況まで何とかしてみようと思います
後輩とね！
ちなみに色合いはこちらの
5色展開となっております
普通に欲しいっ！
てか、俺のだわ
後輩：うそじゃん！！
では、置いていきます
はい、やってる途中で思ったんですけど
床が滑るのでちょっとこのまま回しても
スルリってなるんで
一応なんか滑らないようなシートがあるので
下に…滑らないシートを引きます
後輩：もはやもう
後輩：それはもはや未完成！
待って これはないわ
もう、なんか
ここがひらっべたくて、
飛び出てるやつがあるんすよね
えー、ここまで
赤、青、緑、黄色、白
って並べていった途中に黒が出てきましたー
えー、もうダメだ綺麗な法則が乱れる
すいません
なんか本当は5色で綺麗に並べたかったんですけども
なるべく綺麗に並べていきたいと思います、では
はぁー、はぁー、はぁー
終了しました～～～
はい、とゆうわけで終了しました
はぁ、え～といいつつも
実は1000個全部置けてるわけでは、ありません
滑るシートのサイズ的にも
これだけしか置けなかったんですけども
多分、800個近くはあるのかな
これだけ並べるのに大体３時間ちょいかかりました
外は、朝です
や、けど完璧に並べましたからね
全てのハンドスピナーの歯車同士が
こう、がっつりとかみ合っており
こっち側にあるハンドスピナーを1個押さえて
こう、回すと
全てが連鎖反応して綺麗に回転してしまう
これで多分回れば1000個でも回ると思うんで
とりあえず回していきましょう！
3…2…1…